the capital skyline is very different
now
keeve's 18th century saint andrews
church but with a backdrop of battle
which is getting closer
[Music]
the city's been put under strict curfew
to try to limit the lives lost but
there's no protecting against attacks
like these
a second missile strikes less than a
minute later
the ukrainian demands for a no-fly zone
grow more ardent with every strike and
despite hints of progress on peace talks
the president's chief of staff told us
there were red lines they would not
cross
would you be prepared to give up
tombas
look
i say an answer to your questions
we don't
discuss
our freedom our independence
our territorial integrity our
sovereignty
all another issue
we can see things and disgust
and my presidents
my presidents are ready to sitting
in any days
in any place
but you're not prepared to give up any
territory
yes
no territory yes
they're on the lookout for russian
saboteurs
we filmed the detention of these two
suspects before the capital's curfew
the ukrainians are worried that russian
agents have infiltrated the main city
and are acting as guides for possible
airstrikes leaving tags or markers on
potential targets or just acting as
informants on troop and military
movements
these concerns have heightened over the
past 24 hours as the russian soldiers
inch closer to kiev and the centre of
ukrainian power
amongst those at risk of being trapped
in the capital are scores of surrogate
babies
there are so many the nursery is a
constant hubbub of crying demands for
attention
the babies are being cared for in a
basement which has been turned into an
underground shelter by a very small team
of babysitters
these women have left their families to
look after these little ones after the
baby's actual parents couldn't reach
them because of all the fighting
[Music]
you have to understand this is war this
babysitter says not everyone is able to
come the airports are all closed so
their parents just can't pick them up
we love all the babies another says as
she explains they become part of our
hearts our family and when the parents
do take them away we cry she tells us
but with heavy fighting around the
capital it's meant the women looking
after the babies here are also all that
stands between them and the bombings
there are so many acts of defiance being
played out on these streets
one soldier and his flute and the
national anthem we won't be ruled by
others it goes in so many ways he speaks
for his country
alex crawford sky news kiev